why New Year game racing Jonathan you
were here to show us path of Exile at pc
game of the year 2013 of course for
gamespot you guys have a new content
pack combination that's right tell us
all about it so path of Exile sacrifice
of the veil is being released on match
for and it's essentially a mini
expansion or large content update that
we've been working on for four months
now and we're here to show you one of
the system's exclusively that we haven't
shown pebbles what we eat so this you
guys are shopping it around all this
week I know you've recorded a demo
that's going to be on gamespot com next
week as we're getting a kind of a little
sneak peek on fascia it's like a pre
sneak peek sneak peek yes alright let's
get down to it show us what you got here
great so oh no actually i'm sorry but i
want to show you i love it just cut just
cut to the game and come back for a
second folks i want to show we bought
all this furniture for this set and i
just want to show exciting look dis
everyone needs one of these you treat us
like kingship idea i did open till the
point i said play the game like this on
on the table a little more problem sorry
we can go to game okay so the system i'd
like to show you today is the val skill
gemsa stoker part of excel essentially
the vowel civilization existed two
thousand years before the player plays
the game and in this in this expansion
they've returned and one of the things
that's returned is their system skill
gems now as you know in part of excel
you have the ability to cast various
skills that can be combined in
interesting ways vowel skills however
because they're ancient and brutal they
charged up as you kill enemies so as I
kill monsters I get the ability to use a
more powerful version of the skill and
players asked for ultimate skills for
quite a long time so we're happy to
deliver axles so is this all being
played out in a new area as well a
resist of this already this area here is
part of the game we we have new areas
that we don't want to show in this demo
cool so this system here normally the
arc skill looks roughly like this I hit
three monsters at a time but we have the
vowel arc after killing enough monsters
lets you decimate an entire group as you
can see a change between them for ages
killing these nice then we have another
a few other skills that we can
demonstrate for example we typically
have skill on the game called destiny
did that lets you detonate a single
corpse but if you get a bunch of corpses
together you can use the Val version of
detonate dead I'll just pull some
monsters over to link these corpses here
then I have the ability to detonate one
and the whole group should go up like
that you nice also this is something the
player can use sparingly throughout the
game as they play so much blood we have
some other examples as well for example
I'll just get a group of monsters
together this here is a regular ison
over in the game but the valve ocean
chains from monster's a monster Oh axe
repeating the skill over and over and
that's that's pitch that they can use it
you know every few minutes as they're
playing to punctuate the combat you can
chain a bunch of guys together and
they're just going to destroy them all
that's right so fire walnuts yeah I
think so here so the val fireball school
I just use a cheat to charge it up so I
can all that haha you're so pro at this
yeah so that's the Val file scope now
that one's been augmented with a micro
transactions make it look slightly
better because all the existing
microtransactions we sell which only
affects how things look not that they
play they all apply to these gems of
course yeah so for people who are
watching this this this bother bagel is
a is a free play video game that's right
yes yeah so anyone who's watching this
is thinking might be worth picking us up
I remember when we were talking about
this in the game of the year at
discussions last year anyone who had
played path of exile was incredibly
passionate that it is again thank you we
try very hard to do that hey you guys
are shopping this around obviously based
over in New Zealand and are you looking
to continue expanding on path of Exile
over the next like your best rival years
we have more expansions planned every
four months is what we're rolling them
out so we're very interested to see
players try this one out and we're also
releasing new leagues at the same time
which is a great opportunity for players
to come back and play because as a fresh
start if you optionally want it so yeah
if you've tried path of exile in the
past come and try it again because
there's new content and a fresh start
that puts you at the same playing field
as other people and what I think is one
of most fascinating parts of passive
exiles those challenge leagues that sort
of capture that like that satisfaction
of leveling but you know you like you've
still got your main guy but you can get
into these speed leagues for folks who
don't know much about him Jonathan you
just talk a little bit so in path of
exile and so we we both have as well as
the four-month leagues that we're doing
now we also have a every day we run
these challenge of vents which we call
races which effectively allow players
sort of start from scratch and therefore
may be sort of three to four hours
something like that play in a league
that has sort of augmented mods that
things like you know faster monsters and
you know like maybe they all do mon
shots or something like that and sort of
race against the clock and the other
players to you know do various
challenges very cool now of course the
skill gem system is what you're showing
off here the val skill gems and like you
know that's how you that's how you level
up your your skills your abilities but
the challenge is like the drop is you
can only fit so many skill gems on your
weapon or your hint depending on failure
once you can see it gets relatively
complicated in terms of accommodations
the skull here is Val fiable with
concentrated effect with elemental
proliferation with increased area of
effect with chance to ignite with fire
penetration crazy the guys the guys back
at the office set some crazy combos up
to show who this character nice now are
the is there any drawback to the vowel
gems are they just kind of valuable and
hardly part of it there is a drawback
but we're not ready to talk about it yes
okay on on Friday however at 1pm PST i
believe the embargo lifts and we've
already prepared some footage to show
you which will be on gamespot so i'd
recommend checking it out perfect
kristen johnson thank you very much for
even more content for this wonderful
game on pc i could you just remind
people where a basic and pick up path of
exile they can go to path of Exile calm
or they can find it on Steam it's free
on both platforms perfect it's great
team path of Exile icon wasn't taken I
would have been a real and we tried to
pick a name of the was fantastic I hope
you enjoy the rest of your time here in
the bay area as well